welcome to the NewsHour we begin with
breaking news from the Gulf of Oman
Liberian flagged oil tanker Pacific
Zircon has been struck by an exploding
drone off the coast of Oman the vessel
is operated by singapore-based Eastern
Pacific shipping the company is owned by
Israeli billionaire I don't offer the
company reported only minor damage to
the vessel's hull and says there was no
spillage or of cargo or injuries among
the crew let's uh speak to Timothy
Hawkins who's a commander and spokesman
for the U.S naval fifth Fleet he's
joining us from a Manama that's in
Bahrain welcome to Al Jazeera can you
tell us what you're hearing about this
incident and if indeed it is confirmed
well we're very much aware of an
incident uh as having taken place last
night in the Gulf of Oman very
concerning we will look to put out a
statement as soon as we can but we have
seen historically
um attacks against Merchant shipping in
fact around 2019 we saw increased
threats to freedom of navigation for
merchant Mariners transiting in
international waters in the Middle East
and we responded by establishing a
multinational Maritime partnership
to to reassure and deter these type of
events right and when you say you are
concerned what is your biggest concern
right now
well our biggest concern is any
destabilizing Maritime activity that
takes place in the surrounding Waters
because they are vital to global trade
it is why we maintain an international
presence
especially near the Strait of her moves
and the Baba and Deb it is also why we
have strengthened and expanded our
multinational Partnerships uh one in
which being the international Maritime
security construct which was formed in
response to increased threats to freedom
of navigation in 2019 and
we added two Nations uh this year alone
to that to that partnership
right so um as uh the U.S fifth Fleet I
know you said that you were going to be
putting out a statement soon but what
will uh your next steps be and do you
think that this has the potential to
escalate
well our next steps is to continue doing
what we've been doing and that is to
maintain a persistent presence it is to
work with our regional partners and our
International partners and
and patrolling uh the nearby Waters and
and also working with commercial
shipping to
ensure that they have the information
they need to continue transiting these
critical waterways safely
all right we'll leave it there thank you
so much for speaking to us from